okay so I'm back here with two pretty
fantastic guests this is Mike and Ryan
and I'll have them introduce themselves
but essentially these guys are coming
from what I like to call indie boutique
publishers sounds fancy whether or not
you agree with that you can debate but
these two folks have been in the
industry for a while and I think they're
going to have a lot of really great
insights and gems of wisdom that we're
gonna share in the next half an hour so
if you don't mind guys pick and choose
who would like to intro maybe your
studio what your background is and
through the vision of what you're doing
there's gonna be a lot of that I think
yeah so I'm Ryan
I'm from noodle cake studios we are in
the middle of Canada place called
Saskatoon probably most of you have
never heard of it if you're flying from
Vancouver to Toronto just jump out of
the plane halfway and you'll land in
Saskatoon so yeah we started out in
about 2011 as a first-party studio
making iPhone games and we kind of
pivoted into publishing a little bit
when Android came out the quick TLDR
story is we developed some software and
health's that allowed us to run native
objective-c code on Android figured a
bunch of our indie friends would
probably want to capitalize on this
because none of them were even
supporting Android at the time it was
such a new platform so we use that and
decided instead of you know doing a tech
license or something because unity was
you know looming who we knew these
cross-platform tools were on their way
we decided to make a publishing company
out of it and the catch was we would
take your game
poured it for you for free and then we
would just cut take a cut of the rev
share market it do all that sort of
stuff so our Android catalog is actually
quite massive because we've been doing
this for a while things just kind of
continue to move along and we started
getting developers coming to us who said
hey you can mark it and publish these
games better than we could on any
platform so why don't you take a whole
the whole thing and then so we kind of
moved into a more traditional publishing
role as well still making our own first
party games at the time that we kind of
used to then like snowball and cross
promote our games so every time we
launch a new games it goes
all of our users across all the games
that we have in our catalog which on
Android I think is over a hundred and
some at this point probably now it's
it's getting quite big we still do some
one-off publishing deals but they're
kind of more for the higher-end Indies
if you will so you know the snowman team
we did the Altos series for them we
recently took over the capybara contract
for sword & Sworcery we've worked with
cyan on mists and things like that so we
kind of do some of these bigger ones but
for the most part now we're
cross-platform publishing and moving
into steam and console space now too so
we're kind of running the gamut cool
that was awesome yeah so I'm Mike I'm
the CEO of Iron Horse Games
I don't know worst has been around for
about two years we mostly focus on
publishing idle games Iron Horse if
you're curious is one person and he's
standing here on the stage I would put
out 11 or 12 games since December we're
doing pretty heavy user acquisition
across the portfolio at this point I
mostly focus on small and medium sized
teams one person teams like Ben there
who's one of the teams I work with Ben's
the very talented developer by swarm
simulator if you guys have played that
there's great game prior to that is the
vice-president publishing at congregate
for about four years focusing on their
mobile publishing business yeah that's
the long and short of it great thanks
guys
maybe you can speak a little bit about
you know what's your journey been like
so far as a publisher it's very
different than working for a big company
it's very different than you know being
purely an indie developer so any
thoughts you like to share on what that
journeys been like so far yeah so
challenging is probably one word for it
I think this was mentioned in the
previous talk that that sarah did the
marketplace shifts radically and you
need to respond to it quickly so started
about two plus years ago and in that
time I have changed my business model
fundamentally three times and
successfully dodged a couple of bullets
so hopefully I've got a couple more of
those left in me
the as challenging as it is I think one
of the things that that's great about it
is you can help small and medium-sized
developers actually grow I've had a lot
of conversations with developers where
you know they've actually tried to
dissuade me from signing their games and
working on them I've I've had
conversations where developers have said
are you sure you want to sure you want
to invest in this game like you think
it's really gonna do this well and the
answer nine times out of ten is yes at
least it's gonna do well enough to be
worth the effort to put it out and in
many of the cases it's well enough to to
generate a significant amount of revenue
for myself in the developers so it's
been challenging but if you can adapt
quickly to the changing marketplace on
iOS and on Google Play you you can
capture a lot of success yeah I mean I
can kind of piggyback on that answer
he's right you got to be lean and you
got to be able to move for us our
publishing is where we do the user
acquisition marketing side of things too
but we're also more of a technical
publisher teams will come to us with you
know partially finished projects and it
can range from 25 percent to 85 percent
or doesn't really matter kind of depends
on when they decide they want to reach
out to a publisher so we take on games
of all sorts and sizes and how those
deals work really depends on what we're
what they're looking for and so one of
the big things is yeah like being very
able being very quickly able to adapt to
the market because you know again unity
didn't exist back in the day when we
started this and now it does and it's
everywhere and that totally crushed the
whole porting side of things but we saw
that coming so we had to adjust you know
the fall at the bottom of pricing was a
huge thing we had to adjust for because
back in the day when only four games
came out a month you could charge five
bucks as I came in it was great but now
it's like everyone's releasing a hundred
games a week so you know how do you
acquire users through different means
than just looking for feature placement
on the stores and things like that so
yeah you got to be able to move and
adapt and I think we've been very you
know we've been good at doing that at
the office and still a part of us just
we we like to stick to our roots when it
comes to games and the games were
working with so if it's something we
think is fun and cool we'll probably
figure out a way to work with you too on
it so it doesn't necessarily have to
fall into a single type of genre great
I think if I don't ask this some will
probably ask this during the QA so what
are you looking for in the end games in
indie games specifically that catch your
attention how do you how as an indie
game developer do you create a really
effective pitch to drum up interest
around a publisher such as yourself or
or any of the other publishers out there
yeah so for us we see a lot of pitches
every day I would say we're probably in
the range between 10 and 15 pitches of
games a day that throughout the week you
know we're telling up to over a hundred
pitches we see very wildly range in
quality um but to stand out I mean
you're probably not as clever as you
think you are I'll tell you that right
away because we see a lot so the big
thing for us is when we're looking for
games I mean we obviously looking for
something that we is gonna catch us from
you know it's something is it
interesting is it different you know if
it's very generic run-of-the-mill we've
seen it a million times it's probably
not gonna do that much for us so if it
is a genre of something that exists
already tried to put a unique spin on it
something that that might not be
something we've seen before or if it is
just make sure it's damn good because a
lot of people just stick to a Unity
template and that's it and that's not
gonna help you either because we've
literally been pitched unity' templates
before its potential publishing games so
it's it's it's a pretty wide smattering
of things that we work with but if you
can hook us with something unique
something interesting and you are gonna
sell it just as much as the game is so
are you a competent developer do you
know your stuff do you know you know the
roadmap for your games do you know the
costs to get some things done if you
need funding having your stuff together
is just as important as the game itself
because you know we'll vet you as a
developer and if we think we can't work
with you on something then we'll dump
the game even if the game itself is cool
so yeah piggyback off what she said one
of the first checks that I do what I'm
talking to a developer is if we have a
shared sense of what success is gonna
look like on the title I think a lot of
developers haven't either thought about
that or they think about themselves as
artists as opposed to businessmen you
can't be an artist you can't put the
game out as an art project you just
can't come to me too
publish that game because I won't
publish but we wait you should stock
didn't like it but don't talk to me the
the reality the situation is I'm looking
to help you grow a business and if we
don't share that at the start of our
relationship then that's it's it's over
before it starts
I think the other important point is you
should think about you think about the
game and how you pitch and present the
game the way that I think about it and
how I'm gonna take it to places like
Google and Apple so if you were to come
to me and you know like hey I've got a
game
it's like clash of clans but they're
pandas it's like that's not coming
that's not gonna cut it what I'm really
looking for is something that's gonna
kind of move the genre forward in a way
that's introduces some complexity that
doesn't exist there now and then usually
a presentation or our style that's
slightly different or unique that you
haven't really seen in that genre before
or that's really well executed I think
what I'm trying to tick those boxes
myself I'm not trying to tick them
because those are things that are
inherently interesting to me although
they are interesting I'm taking them
because it helps to differentiate the
title to Apple and Google for featuring
purposes and support and just get their
attention to get feedback on the game so
think about that when you're pitching
games the publishers - it's really
important yeah like we had a game called
chameleon run that we published years
back and that game is basically you've
seen the genre before a hundred million
times it's it's a it's an auto-runner
with a color switching mechanic but the
developer who made it understood how to
push that genre forward in such a unique
way his controls are beyond tight he the
under onboarding was amazing he had a
great visual style and just kind of
pushed it into a way that was like
you've seen it but not like this and it
was great and it was one of those games
that when we got pitched the demo of
that game it was just a couple like demo
levels and we got it over a lunch hour
and we were at a restaurant and a couple
of guys started playing it one guy went
to the washroom stayed in the washroom
and beat the entire demo while he's in
the wash and we all went back to the
office and we knew right away that there
was something there right there was a
hook to that game ended up winning an
Apple Design Award you know has been
editors choice in Google Play you know
he was a huge smash for a game that
essentially at its core still just not a
runner but they pushed the genre forward
so that's definitely something we look
forward to
that's actually me in flip-flops
solitaire yeah I played a whole lot of
that game very basic concept but like
just so well done yeah talk to me about
how you look at success success is a
very broad term and success is something
that means a lot of different things to
different people so let talked to me
about how that looks for you and perhaps
maybe how indie should be looking at
success on on mobile you know for us
success definitely I mean there's the
monetary aspect of it is like the easy
one to just say oh is it going to be
make money for us and the developer I
mean that's that's obviously the
starting point the people are looking at
but what kind of money that makes
definitely can very success to one
developer might be totally different to
another one depending on their needs is
this a full-time gig that you're doing
is it an evening and weekend project
we've had some devs who you know they
just wanted to make their development
money back we've had others who this was
like I might lose my house situation
don't be that developer please please
don't be yeah but there are people there
are Deb's out there like that so you
know there's nothing wrong with being
what I like to call it blue-collar indie
dev like you don't have to set the world
on fire with one game and make a million
dollars and retire it's not probably
going to happen so you know if you make
enough to make your next game that's
success to me yeah for me success is
kind of three three different
definitions there I mean the first for
me and the most obvious was being able
to generate enough revenue to reinvest
back into the business and grow the
business both for myself and for the
developers so that's over the last like
six or so months we've been doing some
pretty heavy marketing and that's all
the bootstrap so that's off of revenues
that been generated off the game they've
been reinvested in the game that lets a
larger revenues that let me reinvest
blah blah and then fund new games as
well so that's that's a Markus success
for me I think you know dovetailing with
what I was saying before about
developers approaching me and not really
seeing what I see in their games I think
it's particularly satisfying for me when
we blow the doors off on a game with us
like a one-man shot
I mean for me I can always I can see
that potential and that's that's why I'm
signing the game of working with that
developer but when the developer kind of
realizes that and they're able to invest
in growing their business that's great
too one of the developers I work with
Sebastian Davies from grumpy Rhino it's
been able to open an office in London
solely off of the revenues we've
generated off of his titles so that's
been totally great and that's a that's a
real mark of success and then something
much more mundane and practical is I
came from really large companies before
this where I spent most of my time
managing people and in meetings as a
daily reminder the success that Iron
Horse is had for me is that I have like
one meeting a week and that's I don't
really do calls I just work and then I
hang out with my two-year-old son and it
is awesome jealous that sounds pretty
awesome okay so there's two things that
I want to follow up with you on that
kind of teased out of what you were just
talking about so one thing that was
mentioned is sustainability so building
off that idea of success like okay it's
one thing to launch a game that does
well but how especially as a smaller
studio in do indie developers how do you
create that sustainability that's like
you know pardon the pun but like the
million dollar question right sure
for me as a publisher it's being a
publisher the reason that you're
publishing games is it distributes your
risk across a number of titles so it's
inherently much more stable than being
an independent if
plus we get snapshots of the market on a
regular basis like however fast your
shipping titles nowhere near how fast
the two of us are shipping titles so
literally you know at least once a
quarter most times it's multiple times
in a quarter we're seeing what the
current snapshot of iOS and Android
looks like how difficult it is to get
features what CPI's look like with
different genres of games and art styles
and so that's that's an advantage of
publishing that a lot of indie
developers don't have one of the hybrid
approaches that we've been trying out at
Iron Horse is to partner developers that
have had success
with new developers that were onboarding
for a portion of the revenue on the new
game and the idea there is the new
developer benefits from the experience
of the older developer they get more
attention than I can really give them
being a single man publisher and it also
helps stabilize them financially a
little bit between launches and it's not
a massive commitment right they're
really playing builds giving feedback on
art style and execution and game
balancing monetization stuff like that
similar to what I do it gives them a
little bit more of a cash flow between
launches and they also get exposed to
some of the stuff that I get exposed to
so they have the added benefit of seeing
information on retention how ads are
performing a modest issue yeah I would
say too if you're looking for like just
as an indie to sustain success I think
you really need to identify what it is
you're trying to create and how long
that's is supposed to take if you're
just making like one-off you know quick
arcade games that kind of thing you need
to set your skull properly because scope
creep is one of the worst things in our
industry and can cost you a lot of money
and then you're not gonna make that back
if your launch doesn't go well so
understanding how you need to release
those kind of games if you're gonna be a
quick rapid-fire making a couple games a
year type of studio or are you a
two-year long investment kind of studio
or something above that and then on that
situation you need to understand how to
build your community how to do your user
acquisition and how to make that game
profitable because you're spending a
hell of a lot more money on that one
than you are in the small ones so you
really understand what your business is
and what you are trying to achieve
because you can't sustain one model by
using a different model and the models
are changing all the time so just ensure
that you're keeping track with the
marketplace what's what's hot what isn't
you know if if you're looking to like I
said pump out a lot of games be on top
of what's being featured you know look
at what Apple and Google like to put you
know a front center because they're
showcasing your game to help represent
their platform so if it's something that
is totally counter to what they're doing
you know you're not playing ball with
the platforms and sometimes you got to
play balls to get to get noticed one
last question
there was also a mention around Mike
you've talked been talking a lot about
you a
there's also community
building which is so important and I
think a lot of really small indie studio
struggle with building a community
building that loyalty not only around
your games but around your studio your
brand talk to me a little bit about that
and it your approach sure community
building I leave up to very capable
developers so if you're curious about
how to build up an active community and
engage with them you should talk to Ben
we're actually just talking about that
at lunch and he does an exemplary job
wading through the trenches with with
players who have a lot of really pointed
feedback about Ben's game and ban
generally so you should it's as far as
marketing and user acquisition I think
there's there's a lot of um mystique
around it right folks think it's some
some impenetrable thing that you need
years of experience to do my general
rule of thumb is you should baby step
when you first start with any user
acquisition and largely ignore what
marketing companies are telling you the
only thing that really matters as far as
you're concerned is did you generate an
equal amount of money or a greater
amount of money from the users that you
acquired than what you spent that's it
like there's nothing they're gonna try
and say uh surely retention because
retention is really strongly coil it's
just ignore all that it's like did that
user give you more money than you spent
on it done it's it's a really simple
math problem I think from there you can
start doing things that are that are
really interesting which is oh did we
have an increased organic impact on one
platform over another I mean I without
shame spend a ton of money on Google
Play and one of the reasons I do it is
because the ROI is great because CP is
are manageable on Google Play but also
there's a huge organic coefficient to my
spend so I do it and I do it a lot and I
try and maximize that on that platform
and I think you don't get to a place
where you're spending six figures on on
a platform overnight I certainly didn't
we started spending I don't know five
thousand dollars in a month or three
thousand dollars in a month you get a
really strong signal about what's
working so you start small build up on
your learnings and then scale your
spending
proprietary get paid out from platforms
which is what I did yeah and no it's
also say no no the game you're working
on and who the players are gonna be so I
mean I'm not you know obviously you're
all working on something different you
might still be making some sort of
premium title you might be we're making
a free-to-play title it doesn't really
matter but how you approach marketing
those games and the community is
definitely going to be different you
know if you're in the free to play space
you know like Mike said the the the
ratio is easy yeah it's the way we do it
too is yeah if you spend too much on a
user then stop doing that because you're
never gonna make money but you know if
you're doing a premium game that isn't
really adhere because you know a
five-dollar premium game you're never
gonna get you know the rates to make
that worth it but then you have to take
a different Road you know get on discord
or something and start building a
community there about your game get on
whatever forums are where people talk
about similar games that yours is and
start drumming up interest that way use
things like pre-registration and you
know other ways to help like drive
engagement especially for a paid game
because you need those users there to
know when it's out because it's it's a
lot harder sell when it's a paid game
versus a free game and and then you know
if you can't do any of that stuff that's
you know he doesn't do as much of that
community engagement we help with some
of that a bit again it's better to
really have the developers talking about
their game than a Salesman it feels a
little greasy er if it's a sales guy
I'm just pitching a game versus an
actual hey I made this kind of thing
we'll work with you on how to set that
up and yeah it's just important to know
where the people are gonna be maybe you
want to get your game featured on
polygon you're probably not gonna but
you know we can I can at least open the
doors for you and we can work on that
kind of stuff so it's it's things like
that like understanding what your game
is and being realistic about that and
not just thinking that you're gonna set
the world on fire with every single game
because again that's not the case
there's a lot of games that come out and
not a lot of make money so my personal
favorite is reddit free tool and that's
actually how I've discovered a couple of
games and recommended folks to apply for
indie corner featuring that's a little
self-promotion there okay awesome thanks
guys